各位曲波科技教师的观众朋友大家好我是曲波
讲到极紫外光EUV
大家一定会想到荷兰的爱斯摩尔公司
但是啊各位知道吗
在极紫外光的设备里面啊
最关键的光学元件
其实都是德国的蔡司公司提供
换句话说
没有蔡司公司的光学技术
就没有爱斯摩尔成功的极紫外光设备
那么蔡司公司啊
除了提供极紫外光里面
关键的光学元件设备之外
还提供哪些半导体的制程跟检测设备呢
今天我们来和大家谈谈这个题目
所以我们今天的题目是
探索未知领域突破科学极限
蔡司如何让半导体设备超越世界
首先我们和大家谈谈
为什么人工智慧晶片的制造难度日益提高
再来我们介绍当结构已经看不见
该如何进行控制
再来我们谈谈蔡司如何参与半导体制造
以及每一颗晶片都从一份蓝图开始
再来我们和大家谈谈如何在缺陷演变为失效之前
及早将其找出
再来我们介绍如何理解失效发生的真正原因
最后我们和大家谈谈
蔡斯如何让半导体设备超越世界
首先大家可能会好奇
为什么人工智慧晶片的制造难度日益提高
到底是什么
让今日的晶片和过去的晶片产生根本性的差异
首先就是人工智慧和高效能运算
持续的提升效能的要求
而且更大的运算力
需要电晶体更维系的结构尺寸
也就是先进制程
再加上立体晶片架构
以及先进封装
解决先进制程的极限
最后造成现代的晶片运算能力持续提升
同时制造和制程控制的复杂度也大幅的增加
半导体产业
在过去这半个世纪
持续的大幅成长
特别是人工智慧
成为推动半导体产业重要的推手
从1990年代
个人电脑的市场大幅的成长
半导体的产值大约500亿美元
到2002年
智慧型手机市场大幅成长
使得产值达到1410亿美元
再到2018年
机器学习产生大量的资料数据
使得半导体的产值达到4660亿美元
未来到2030年
半导体的产值将会大幅成长到1.3兆美元
在这个过程中
总共经历了四个不同的时代
第一个时代是大型主机的时代
成长到第二个时代是个人电脑和网际网路的时代
再成长到第三个时代是行动通讯的时代
最后成长到第四个时代是人工智慧的时代
而人工智慧的时代将是运算需求最大的时代
而且整个半导体产业发展到结构已经看不见
该要如何进行控制
也就是当前的半导体产业面临最大的制造挑战是什么
首先先进制成原件的尺寸萎缩造成隐藏的结构和缺陷越来越多
而且不断缩小的制成会造成误差的容许度越来越严格
再加上日益复杂的制造流程需要更多的检测技术
因此随着结构尺寸持续萎缩架构日益复杂
制造商需要更可靠的方法来侦测量测
并且理解那些已经无法直接观察的结构和缺陷
大家都知道半导体先进制程的演进
从20nm以上的制程节点
使用金属氧化物半导体敞效电晶体MOSFET
发展到20nm以下的制程节点
使用歧视敞效电晶体FINFET
再发展到3nm以下的制程节点
使用环绕杂集敞效电晶体GAAFET
电晶体的尺寸越来越小
复杂度越来越高
当电子通道从垂直的平板状结构
变成水平的平板状结构
半导体的制程变得更复杂
特别是环绕杂级敞效电晶体的制作
必须先成长一层一层的累金薄膜
再将电子通道下方的累金薄膜掏空
并且填入黄色的氧化层和绿色的金属
其次场效电晶体为了提高良率
在制作的过程中
必须常常使用光学检测或电子显微镜检测
每一层结构是否完成
而环绕杂机场效电晶体
在制作的过程中
很难使用光学检测或电子显微镜检测
观察内部的结构是不是制作的完美
因此很难提高制成良率
同样的在台积电的晶片堆叠
晶圆堆叠载版
CoA-S封装最上面的处理器
和两旁的高频宽记忆体
堆叠在系中介板上
再堆叠到导线载板上
针对先进封装
我们也很难从外面去观察到
晶片内部封装的结构是不是完整
因此我们需要先进的检测设备
那么蔡司如何参与半导体制造呢
如何超越单一制程
为整体的半导体制造提供技术资源
这里面包括围影技术
以及光照的制程控制
还有检测和量测技术私销分析
因此蔡斯的技术涵盖半导体制造的关键环节
从产品和制程开发一路延伸到高量产
特别是先进制程所使用的极止外光设备
里面用到许多的光学元件
是启动下一代先进制程的发展最重要的技术
大家看到的这个就是极止外光设备的光学元件
包括半导体制造光学元件
主要用于光学围影以及光照的解决方案
适用于大批量晶圆生产的解决方案
右边这个图是先进半导体制造的光学系统
包括围影的光学系统
反射镜组和晶圆承载盘
以及晶圆检测和围影用的雷射光学系统
量测设备和零组件
以及同步光学系统和光学收集系统
此外 蔡司提供光照的解决方案
包括光照的量测 光照的校正 光照的修复光照的验证 以及自动化应用特别是极紫外光这种未来的新光源所使用到的光学系统是经过了30年的研发超过1200个合作伙伴
超过2000个专利
而目前极紫外光系统已经进展到下一代的高素质孔径极紫外光
它的光学系统接收光线的入射角范围越来越大
所能够解析和呈现的细微结构就越来越精细
而决定光学系统角度涵盖范围的关键参数
就称为数值孔径NA
相较于传统的极脂外光围影系统
数值孔径0.33
下一代的高数值孔径极脂外光
它的数值孔径0.55
具备更大的开口角度
因此能够进一步提升围影的解析度
支援更先进的半导体制程节点
而蔡斯提供了全世界最精确的反射镜面
在极脂外光系统里面的反射镜表面是由超过100层的细和木的多层薄膜交替堆叠而成
每一层的厚度只有相当于数个原子层形成的布拉格反射镜
可以反射高达70%的极脂外光达到世界领先的反射效率
而且反射镜表面必须达到次原子尺度的超高精确度
必须拥有极高的精密量测以及表面控制能力
同时蔡斯建立了真空环境下的先进量测技术
这是一个150吨级的极致精密工程
高速值孔径及指外光技术所使用的反射镜量测系统
是蔡斯迄今为止打造最复杂的精密量测设备
这一套系统必须在高真空的环境下运作
因此蔡斯必须建造出庞大的真空系统
来满足光学圆圈对极致精度的要求
使得这项突破性的量测技术得以实现
而每一颗晶片都是从一份蓝图开始
为什么极止外光的检测
让光照可靠度可以进一步提升
蔡司的半导体光照解决方案
包括光照量测
校正修复和光照的验证
因为每一颗晶片都是死于一片光照
而每一个成功的量产制程
都是死于对这片光照的高度信心和可靠度验证
那么晶圆制造商是如何在光照正式投入量产之前
确认它的功能正确
可以将电路图形转移到细晶圆上呢
因此蔡斯提供光照缺陷修复和校正相关的技术
包括光照定位量测
Proof光照的校正 for tune
硬缺陷与软缺陷修复的merit PRT
以及光照验证AMPS
另外可以检测修复前的光照缺陷
利用蔡斯的merit
截取影像显示图案中的缺陷
而蔡斯的AMS光场分布影像
可以显示如何转化成光照上面的晶圆曝光结果
所以左边这个图案就是光照修复前的缺陷
而右边这个图案就是AMS光场分布影像
可以显示转化成光照上晶圆曝光的结果
经由修复后的光照缺陷
利用蔡斯Merit透过聚焦电子数结合气体辅助资源
可以进行可靠的光照修复和缺陷校正
再使用蔡司的AMS
验证修复后的光照品质
因此使用merit
透过聚焦电子素
结合气体辅助资源
可以修复光照
再利用AMS
验证修复后的光照品质
极紫外光系统
主要有极紫外光的雷射光源
发出极紫外光之后
经过反射镜反射
再经由反射式的光照
将我们所需要的图形反射之后
再经由反射镜反射投影在晶圆表面
因为极脂外光会被空气吸收
也会被石英吸收
因此极脂外光必须在真空系统中
而且所有的透镜都必须改用反射镜
其中极脂外光雷射光源
透过中间焦点发射出来
这一系列的反射镜
称为照明光学系统
反射到光照之后
将图形反射回投影光学系统
最后投影在晶圆表面
蔡斯提供高精度的光学元件
包含两个功能模组
左边这个是投影光学系统
里面含有超过4万个单独的元件
大约12吨重
右边这个是照明光学系统
具有超过25,000个独立的元件
大约6吨重
从这张图可以看出
蔡斯提供的光学系统
是极脂外光曝光机里面
最关键的设备
另外蔡司的AMS EUV设备
是高素质孔径世代的光照成像验证平台
机子外光的光照在使用之前
必须利用验证平台来验证光照成像的正确性
所以这一台设备开启了感光性的光照验证新机缘
提供全面的模拟功能
精准模拟高素质孔径
HighNA的成像物理效应
而且单一平台可以支援低素质孔径
LowNA和高素质孔径
HighNA的光照验证
让光照检测的产能提升三倍
同时支援非等向的缩放
先进光照量测
以及数位柔性插图
进行数位化模拟
各种先进曝光模式和制成情境
右边这一台就是
蔡司的AMS EUV
高素质孔径光照成像验证平台
当我们设计光照之后
可以利用这个平台
得到模拟影像来验证
最后制作的图形结构
和我们所设计的相同
右边这个就是实际制作在细晶圆上的扫描式电子显微镜照片
那么如何在缺陷演变成失效之前
及早把它找出来呢
当晶片的结构已经无法透过传统的方法进行检验该怎么办
因此蔡司提供半导体晶圆制造解决方案
里面包含检测和制程的控制半导体前段到后段制程也就是电晶体的制程和多层导线的制程乃至于先进封装制程可能发生的晶圆翘区检测
和修复技术
Doom DUNE
另外还有先进封装3D架构
隐藏缺陷和先进检测技术
NLX
总之现代的半导体制程
需要全新的检测方法
才能够在隐藏缺陷影响良率和效能之前
及早将这些缺陷侦测出来
因此蔡斯的半导体晶圆制造解决方案
包括隐藏缺陷与先进检测技术NLX
适用在先进封装的Inline 3D X-Ray检测
也就是利用X光穿透封装的外部看到里面的结构
可以提供跨越晶圆边缘的一致性3D成像和分析
专为线上整合和高通量的检测设计
因此可以在生产线上快速进行检测
而且可以针对特定区域的X-Guard辐射控制限制辐射的剂量
右边这一台就是MLX隐藏缺陷和先进检测设备
针对先进封装结构的3D量测技术
可以看到垂直堆叠之后的影像
包括晶片和晶片之间的焊息图块尺寸是否正确
以及互联结构和界面的3D缺陷检测
也就是垂直堆叠晶片之间的缺陷检测
此外,蔡斯提供晶圆翘区检测与修复技术DUNE
可以进行先进半导体制造的全域晶圆形状控制
晶圆形状的校正范围可以延伸到晶圆的边缘
针对每片晶圆进行翘区优化
我们知道在先进封装的时候
晶圆减薄可能会造成翘区
因此必须进行优化
整合式晶圆表面的形状扬侧
可以应用的领域涵盖前段制程后段制程和先进封装
包括3D的记忆体还有逻辑晶片
先进封装和晶圆接合
以及其他晶圆甚至面板的应用
例如影像感测器功率元件
甚至其他2D 3D机体电路相关的封装技术
右边这一台就是DOOM DUNE晶圆区检测与修复设备
那么我们如何理解失效发生的真正原因呢
如何定位隔离辨识半导体晶片内的物理性或者电性的缺陷
这个就必须进行根本原因分析RCA
例如使用3D X光显微镜交叉光束镭射聚焦离子素
这一种分析方法
进行精力层级的失效分析
以及晶圆层级的失效分析
透过高品质的影像和截面分析
结合人工智慧的关联式分析整个工作流程
并且深入到奈米的尺度
就可以快速的取得关键的结果
并且缩短分析取得的时间
因此蔡斯提供3D X光显微镜
针对完整封装进行高解析度的成像
这是一种非破坏性的检测
可以观察埋藏在内部的缺陷
不需要破坏封装
因为使用X光穿透封装外壳
可以分析内部隐藏的缺陷
而且无缝整合标准失效分析
直接融入现有的封装失效分析流程
这是使用业界顶尖的影像品质
提供高品质高解析度的3D成像能力
并且使用独特的远距解析度技术
针对先进封装进行高解析度的成像
包括细中介板、细穿孔、堆叠的晶片
以及附近使用的微凸块等结构
也就是右边这一台设备
同时蔡司提供Crossbit雷射交叉光束雷射
使用雷射整合聚焦离子素扫描式电子显微镜
利用雷射快速的切削样品的表面
再使用聚焦离子素
微小的切削样品的表面
就可以加速封装失效分析的分析结果
快速到达目标的区域
可以分析封装内部隐藏的结构和缺陷
而且使用雷射切削的方式
可以大幅缩短聚焦离子素的作业时间
相较于传统的设备
截面制作的速度可以提升200%
而且具有优异的样品品质
跟最高等级的成像效能
兼顾高品质样品的自备
还有高解析度的影像分析
用这样的技术
也可以进行先进
穿透式电子显微镜
TEM的样品自备
可以快速解消
穿透封装和堆叠精力的结构
而且可以广泛的应用在各种材料
包括碳化系和玻璃
这些先进封装材料
也就是右边这一台设备
另外蔡司也推出
Jemina厂发射扫描式电子显微镜
针对完整封装进行高解析度的成像
这是一种无尽润式的光学系统
避免对电子特性良测造成干扰
可以进行原件电性和结构的同步分析
同时它属于超低电压高解析度的成像
适用在对电子素敏感的先进制程
可以降低电子素对样品造成的影响
进行大范围无丝针的视野
还有极高画素解析度
可以分析大尺寸的电路结构
并且精确的监控探针的弱点
同时经过验证的稳定性和效能
可以支援5nm以下的先进制程节点
以及后续更先进的技术世代
也就是右边这一台设备
那么利用3D X光显微镜检测的实际案例
包括记忆体和逻辑晶片的互联密度
持续的增加
从传统封装到附近封装
到散出型封装
2.5D封装
甚至混合建核技术
先进封装的互联密度
不断的增加
而且一直整合的连线在2.5D封装里面
应用越来越广泛
这张图里面包含印刷电路板
导线载板细中介板
其中记忆体使用3D封装
微凸块大概10到40微米
处理器的微凸块小于5微米
而处理器和记忆体使用细中介板
互相连线同柱大约20到80微米
最后连接到导线载板上在经由外部金属球尺寸大约400到800尾米连接到印刷电路版上和系中介版经由附近图块尺寸大约40到250维米连接到导线载版上
再连接外部金属球尺寸大约400到800维米
这样的封装称为球阁阵列BGA最后连接到印刷电路版上
利用蔡司的3DX光显微镜检测
可以看到不同尺寸下面的微图块
混合建核以及附近图块
此外使用雷射整合式聚焦离子素
扫描式电子显微镜
可以将样品表面切削
观察我们想要看到深度的影像
从宏观的角度
对于应用和样品的多样性很重要
从围观的角度
对于奈米级的分析也很重要
使用加聚焦离子素
适合应用在奈米等级的
样品表面洗销从3奈米到100奈米到100维米
但是不适合应用在宏观维米等级的样品表面洗销
而使用电浆聚焦离子素
适合应用在100奈米到200维米的样品表面洗销
却不适合应用在奈米等级或者维米等级的样品表面洗销
只有使用蔡司提供的雷射整合聚焦离子素
适合应用在奈米等级一直到维米等级
所有范围的样品表面洗消
因为使用雷射
可以快速的将样品表面
大量的体积进行洗消
不需要中断
同时使用聚焦离子素
就可以高解析度的快速
将样品表面研磨移除
传统的设备
必须使用雷射玻璃
再加上电浆聚焦离子素
处理样片需要3个小时10分钟
而使用雷射整合式的聚焦离子素
可以利用雷射玻璃
再利用聚焦离子素
抛光样品表面将整个试片处理的时间
缩短到一个小时25分钟
右边这个图就是使用交叉光束雷射
移除样品表面所拍摄的扫描式电子显微镜照片
此外蔡司也提供线上的制程控制设备
蔡司3D量测和检测解决方案
可以结合高解析度的成像和逐层玻璃的技术
再加上强大的资料处理能力
提供领先业界的3D成像和重建
左边这个照片是NAM杂形快闪记忆体的3D成像和重建
可以精确量测所有相关的结构参数
右边这个图是动态随机存取记忆体DRAM的元件
这是市场上唯一可以完整重建电容单元
也就是深沟槽电容和主动区域的解决方案
另外蔡司的设备也可以进行晶片特性和私销分析
在1000伏特下5奈米的静态随机存取记忆体
可以进行被动电压对比成像
也就是左边这个图
另外在80伏特下
针对7奈米的静态随机存取记忆体
可以进行成像和探针定位
也就是第二个图
可以利用奈米级的探针
施压在电晶体的特定位置
来针对静态随机存取记忆体进行量测
也可以对5奈米的静态随机存取记忆体
断层扫描资料进行3D视觉化
也就是这个图所呈现的结果
甚至是全自动的穿透式电子显微镜
体验薄片的自备
包括取出转移和减薄
进行样品薄片自备
也就是这一张照片显示的样品
另外菜丝的设备
可以提供封装开发和故障分析
使用次微米解析度
来进行智慧型手机电路版的
非破坏性3DX光显微镜检测
或使用雷射整合聚焦离子素
扫描式电子显微镜
针对2.5D封装中深埋的微凸块来进行检测
或是使用无丝针大视野成像的2.5D封装里面
观察微凸块还有导线重布层的结构
另外蔡司针对表面粘贴元件和系统整合
也提供相关的解决方案
包括表面粘贴被动元件的扫描式电子显微镜检测
以及使用蔡司的Visioner One对印刷电路板元件进行光学检测
或使用蔡斯的LSM900MAT
透过共二胶成像
进行表面粗糙度和轮廓分析
或使用蔡斯Metroton
对印刷电路板进行非破坏性X光检测
最后蔡斯也提供系统计量和品质保证
使用蔡斯的Metroton
进行X光电脑断层扫描
针对基座插头的成像量测
或是使用蔡斯的Odetect
进行印刷电路板的光学量测
随后可以使用蔡司的Hepistole
针对结果进行详细的分析
总之蔡司提供全方位解决方案
涵盖半导体的每一个关键环节
参与半导体制造多个关键环节
而且这些环节共同的核心
都是如何看见量测
并且理解极其微小而且高度复杂的结构
这个不只依赖单一的技术
而是结合蔡司在光学精密量测
以及显微分析这些领域的专业能力
来协助客户管理日渐复杂的半导体制造流程
这些设备包括光照的制造
微影的制程
线上的制程分析设备
晶圆晶片的特性分析和失效分析
以及封装开发和故障分析
甚至原件组装和系统整合
以及计量统计和品质保证
菜丝提供全方位的半导体制程
以及检测设备
欢迎大家加入知识力专业社群
你的专属科技顾问
今天我们简短的和大家介绍
蔡司完整的半导体制程
以及检测设备
大家如果对这些设备有兴趣
别忘了报名
SemiCon 台湾2026
到蔡司展览的摊位
亲自参与现场的解说
这样会对蔡司的技术更有感觉哦
好 我们今天的节目到这边
大家对于蔡司提供的半导体相关设备
有任何问题
欢迎大家发表在影片的下方
我们再来讨论
谢谢大家
晚安 拜拜
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive